I've waited my entire life to arrive but
arriving is not the end of the journey
it's just the
beginning you
are Benjamin Franklin then Napoleon
Maxine Simons
who it's could change
things creation is our way
forward there's more to you that meets
the a
[Applause]
there are endless possibilities out
there m what flavor is this Jin that's
what I'm tasting do we have an alliance
we have a
battle I was the first to see her dead
they say you were the last to see her
alive you are the best lawyer that I
know and I need
you I was born with a chance to be
somebody our existence is all about
choices I am never in over my head it
would be disrespectful to my
hairdresser yeah that's quite
impressive we're doing
[Music]
this
this is the
time